as leaders I see people getting caught
up all the times in little things that
will not affect the outcome unless they
let it so I see some white belt below
them in the chain of commands going all
crazy grabbing their sleeve and this
leader on the top like it gets concerned
about it and puts time and effort into
something that doesn't matter whether
it's a little personality rub a little
ego uprising
should we do it this way or should we do
it that way it doesn't matter that's a
little sleeve grab it doesn't matter and
I see people getting caught up on things
that don't matter all the time and what
I've realized is it's something that I
figured out a long time ago I don't know
win but a long time ago I figured out
you know what that thing doesn't matter
I'm not gonna worry about it that thing
doesn't matter I'm not gonna worry about
it that thing doesn't matter I'm not
gonna worry about it
that thing matters I'm gonna focus on
that thing mm-hmm and that makes that
makes a big a big big big difference
it's its leadership capital because if
I'm investing my leadership capital and
getting your hand off my sleeve or
trying to do it my way instead of your
way or trying to keep your ego in check
if that's what I'm investing my
leadership capitalist I have nothing
left invest in the thing that's actually
matters just like if you're a black belt
and someone guys grabbing your sleeve
and you focus on pulling that hand off
your whole time you're gonna waste
energy and maybe you even give up
position because you're because you're
focused on something that did not matter
so it is important to realize and to
learn to differentiate between things
that don't matter and things that do
matter in an order to tell the
difference between those two things you
have to be able to detach and step back
and obviously this is the same thing
not just with jujitsu not just with
leadership not just with combat because
it's the same thing in combat you're
gonna have things that don't things are
happening on the battlefield that don't
matter
little hey guys moving here instead of
there that doesn't matter oh this guy's
moving there so it doesn't matter the
enemy's doing this okay it doesn't
matter oh wait the enemy did that say
that matters one of my guys did this
thing that matters
so how do you learn to discriminate
between the two you have to be able to
detach from it that's what you have to
do you have to be able to detach and if
you if you don't learn to detach you're
gonna constantly get tripped up on
things that don't really matter and I'll
tell you the more the better you get the
less things matter the better you get
the last thing is matter and the better
you get the more the more important
things matter hmm so you you end up just
wasting no energy on things that don't
matter and focusing all your energy on
things that actually matter and this is
the difference man this is how you win
in jujitsu this is how you win as a
leader this is how you win in combat and
this is truly how you win in life think
about all the things you know what you
used to talk about a lot you haven't
done in a while you talk about
distractions how things can distract you
that's totally true that's what I'm
talking about the things that distract
you from what actually matters so you
have to you have to figure out how to
detach from those things I was doing
some reading as is per norm and there's
a guy named Keith Douglas he was a
British soldier World War two he's kind
of a badass he was stuck in an
administrative position in October of
1942 during the Second Battle of El
Alamein and so he's stuck in this
administrative position so he's in when
AWOL and went to the frontline and
joined the fight and got after it and
one of the things that he wrote he said
to be sentimental or emotional now is
dangerous to oneself and to others so
what is he talking about you can't get
emotional you can't get sentimental you
can't get caught up in things that don't
matter after his return from Africa this
guy Keith Douglas he wrote a book about
his experience here's a little excerpt
you can kind of
think about what this guy has been
through that taught him these lessons
here we go as I came up to them I
recognized one of them as Robin the
observation officer whose aid I had been
asking for earlier in the day I
recognized his fleece lines fleece-lined
suede waistcoat and polished brass
shoulder titles and then his face
strained and tired with pain his left
foot was smashed to a pulp mingled with
the remainder of a boot but as I spoke
to Robin saying have you got a
tourniquet Robin
he answered apologetically I'm afraid I
haven't Keith I looked at the second man
only his clothes distinguished him as a
human being
his face had gone in place of it was a
huge yellow vegetable the eyes blinked
in it without lashes into grotesque huge
mouth dribbled and moaned like a child
exhausted with crying so there's an
example of a horrible situation that you
have to learn to detach and you have to
be able to focus on things that actually
matter because as Keith Douglass said to
be sentimental or emotional now is
dangerous to oneself and to others now
as I was digging into a little bit of
Keith Douglass and up we'll get to Keith
Douglass fully on the podcast but he he
added to that line he added another line
that I want to hit as well to be
sentimental or emotional now is
dangerous to himself and to others and
he continues to trust anyone or to admit
any hope of a better world it's
criminally foolish
as foolish as it is to stop working for
it so right you know that's a little
tangent that's a tangent but it's
powerful
and like I said we'll get to Keith's
Douglass's book and that book got
published after the war and
unfortunately Keith Douglas never saw
that book get published because he was
killed by enemy mortar fire On June 9th
just a few days into the d-day invasion
of Normandy which he took pardon but
again luckily he left us a lesson which
is to control your emotions and I think
as a as a person and as an individual if
you can start trying to discriminate
between things that matter and things
that don't matter and the way that you
do that is by detaching from everything
and then you can pay attention you can
assess logically not emotionally what's
important what's not and you focus on
the things that matter and it's gonna
make your entire life a lot easier it's
a great lesson from Keith Douglas